il ya quelques jours je vous emmener au
crs avec moi à las vegas et il ya un
stand que j'ai visités j'ai vu plein de
trucs intéressants
je vous en ai pas encore parlé au
programme on va aller voir de robots qui
font de la cuisine on va aller voir une
porte connectés hypra intelligente du
futur et compagnie c'est ça des
nouvelles télés huit cas on va les voir
plein de choses intéressantes
tout ça ça se passe chez sgs geostat us
non des visions d'avenir ya
effectivement beaucoup de produits finis
mais il ya aussi une espèce
d'anticipation autour de la technologie
autour de la robotique et des choses
vraiment intéressantes je vous montre ça
vous allez voir vous allez pas être au
bout de vos surprises
[Musique]
le
e
[Musique]
exactement régnant depuis qu'on a sorti
le led ya quelques années maintenant les
tailles de l'aide commençaient à 55
pouces 55 65 77 voire 80 épouse depuis
les huit cas et on nous demandait
régulièrement et pourquoi au fait pas
des oled plus petit qu'on les voit aussi
un petit peu moins cher et démocratiser
la technologie on sort cette année pour
la première fois un écran oled une
taille de 48 pouces 48 48 pouces et le
ces dix qui sortira en avril 2020 dans
le monde et donc en france forcément
bien donc on est très content de pouvoir
proposer sa dorénavant à l'ensemble du
marché comme il est du tarif ou pas pas
encore or pas vous communiquer les
tarifs monza sera moins cher que les
écrans oled en commercialisent
généralement la sacem dans cette api
qingming on peut jouer dessus oui on
peut y jouer dessus parce que sur tous
les écrans oled et depuis la fin de
l'année dernière deux écrans oled sont
compatibles avec nvidia geessink ça veut
dire que vous pouvez jouer et branché un
pc dessus et pour un écran de 48 pouces
sur une taille qui est donc un peu plus
petit c'est vachement intéressant parce
que grâce à nvidia est ici que vous
allez avoir un temps de latence des
temps de rafraîchissement qui sont
booster au maximum et d'encore une
expérience gaming extrêmement aboutie on
est les seuls aujourd'hui sur le marché
à avoir cette compatibilité pour des
télés et celle oled permet de faire ça
vous présenter cette année sur le cs un
système de portes intelligent et un
système de livraison très ingénieux
parce que vous savez vous n'êtes pas
forcément tous les jours chez vous êtes
en vacances et travailler beaucoup pour
pouvoir vous livrer vos courses et les
choses que vous avez commandé même quand
vous n'êtes pas là
vous commandez sur internet le livreur
va recevoir un qr code sur son portable
ce qr code va être utilisée devant être
fort
scanner
comme étant reconnu on va reconnaître sa
livraison
igor accès à deux compartiments depuis
lecteurs de la maison
un compartiment duo qui est réfrigéré et
un compartiment du baril
et paraît tri gérer en fonction si vous
devez livrer des cours est donc utilisé
le réfrigérer vous faire livrer un
portable un beau symbole un bel objet
high-tech
il va être placé en bas quand les
livraisons est terminée elle juste
besoin de refermer ces deux
compartiments auquel vous aurez accès
depuis l'intérieur de votre maison
c'est un système de livraison
intelligent qui vous permet de vous
faire livrer les choses quand cette
phalange cette porte aussi une porte
intelligente qui va vous reconnaitre
quand vous rentrez chez vous grâce à un
système de reconnaissance faciale et un
système de reconnaissance de votre main
en connaissant les placements des veines
dans votre main de la démonstration
[Musique]
la personne a été reconnue
on appuie sur ce petit bouton
et la porte s'ouvre automatiquement
derrière on ait basculé côté intérieure
dhs à l'intérieur de chez vous vous
ouvrez ses placards vous avez accès à la
livraison qui ont été déposés et en
retour et ce compartiment l'écran vous
donne le récapitulatif de la livraison
qui a été fait avec les ingrédients
lirait et le total de la commande de
grâce aux qr code
quand is khan sans couleur chronique
c'est qu'elle commande est censé arriver
qui sait les produits qu'ils sont
arrivé ici sur ce crs en vous prenant
également chanté pour la première fois
un système de potagers d'intérieur chez
vous
la tendance est toujours de fait les
choses vous même et aussi fait grandir
faites pousser vos légumes chez vous en
référence sur le court plantes la salade
la laitue la roquette basilic persil il
gère la lumière la température et
l'irrigation
ce sont des petits pots qui sont
préétablis avec à l'intérieur la graine
de la mousse de clubs et de l'engrais
que vous mettez à chaque étape chaque
étage une typologie de ten est seul à
prendre entre deux et six semaines pour
faire pousser les herbes et la plante en
question il y avait un type au logis de
plantes différentes qui peuvent être
mises en situation ici
c'est une vraie nouveauté qu'on présente
au cv cette année vous présente chez lg
on se laisse aussi un écran intelligent
qui vous permettent d'essayer
virtuellement des vêtements quand vous
faites des commandes de vêtements sur
internet une des points des premiers
motifs de retour c'est les problèmes de
taille qui n'est pas commander votre
vêtement à la bonne taille
cet écran cet écran on va vous scannez
on va prendre vos mesures le cou les
épaules le bassin les hanches et va vous
fait un avatar qui va personnaliser à
votre taille redonnant vraiment vos
vraies dimensions
et vous allez pouvoir essayer
virtuellement des vêtements et bouger
détails voir comment un vêtement ou la
taille s voir comment votre nom bataille
m taille elle vous allez pouvoir pouvoir
quelle taille vous correspond le mieux
et ensuite commander directement le
vêtement directement sur sur l'écran
celle e-commerce ou demain pour éviter
les problèmes de taille quand vous
commandez les vêtements sur internet
quelque chose que tu as 3 par exemple le
trias dans une chambre à coucher dans un
resto
pourquoi pas tu pourra retrouver ça chez
toi ou dans certaines solutions
e-commerce de demain on pourra parler
notre commune au restaurant on est dans
une zone particulière en effet sur notre
stand au ces le cd je t'emmène au
restaurant où les jetant m non pas
n'importe lequel restaurant dans un
restaurant qui gérait 100% par des
robots coup de a à z et non tu arrives
dans le restaurant elle devait être
prise en charge par ce robot là qui est
le robot que tu trouve déjà dans les
aéroports à séoul en corée
s'appelle le kate moss et qui va te
prendre en charge et qui va t'emmener à
ta table
facile à juste à côté pour l'instant
s'asseoir ici j'ai pris en charge
ensuite ou par de petits robots clones
ça va être accompagnée de vents toujours
pas sur ce robot tu vas pouvoir passer
ta commande choisir tes clopes
qu'est ce que tu veux manger la commande
va être envoyée directement ou en
cuisine mais en cuisine ce sont des
robots qui vont commencer à préparer ton
plat ou une fois d'accord en effectuer
les robots sont en plein travail
pourquoi vous préparer ton plat wellink
a commandé des nouilles et robots on
pourra aller chercher des portions de
nous y préparer les mettre dans l'eau
bouillante les sortir les égoutter et
basculer dans l'assiette aller chercher
la sauce et la bascule dans ton assiette
aussi sont déplacés simple qu'il faut
préparer on n'est pas sur des robots qui
vont pouvoir couper push et ce genre de
choses là mais sur des avec des missions
assez préparés et à simple à utiliser
peut avoir de type 2
lisa sion un site de démonstration dans
un restaurant sans qu'on soit automatisé
ta commande est prête elle est prête à
être délivré à table c'est ce robot là
le surf boat
grâce à un système de plateau à
l'arrière prendre en charge sa commande
est de l'amener directement à table
quand on est à table quand tu as fini de
manger c'est ton nous aussi c'est à
nouveau le petit robot que louis auquel
tu veux dire j'ai fini de manger je peux
et débarrassez vous robot qui à venir
débarrasser la table et venir 30 et
plateau et ses plateaux vont être emmené
au dernier robot qui s'occupe de faire
le prélavage de ta vaisselle et qui va
poser ensuite assiette
bol vert dans le système de vaisselle on
va dire plus classique à grande échelle
sur les moniteurs en fonction de la
personnalité guennic nous a présenté à
l'ifa l'an dernier avec la technologie
nano ubs
d'entre elles
l'ess des moniteurs qui s'appelle
hippolyte heures rko on vous voyez ici
ils ne sont pas sur un pied mais ils
sont sur un bras articulé qui a vocation
de venir se placer aux extrémités de
votre bureau et qui vont lui donner une
flexibilité unique pour le placer et le
personnaliser en fonction de votre
consommation moniteur à l'horizontale
à la verticale
vous pouvez le monter
de descendre par rapport à votre bureau
et l'affiné
tu dois vraiment comme ça tombait
vraiment comme tu veux au saut du lit
vraiment comme tu veux tu positionne et
il peut tout faire un bureau terran
personnalisable en fonction de la
technique de la typologie de travail et
d'activités que tu en train faire
surtout moniteur du nouveau sur nos
téléviseurs en 2020 au niveau du
processeur on passe à la troisième
génération du processeur alphanov et ce
processeur va nous permettre d'apporter
quelques nouveautés en termes de
amélioration du son et de l'image sur
vos télés amélioration de l'image on va
pouvoir par exemple certes misé l'image
qui va reconnaître automatiquement des
visages et du texte et va ajuster la
netteté
grain de votre peau l'optimiser pourtant
vraiment magnifique sur votre télé il ya
une intelligence artificielle derrière
rien évidemment
on a toujours les systèmes de pascaline
pour remonter la qualité d'un crime
ajoute notre source
transformer tu as acheté en 4k retombées
du 4k en 8k aussi bien évidemment puurs
leçon on a aussi un système
d'intelligence qui va permettre quand
vous avez une personne qui parle dans la
rue comme ici par exemple isolé savoie
et de la remontée pour qu'elle soit
encore plus au nord est en sens inverse
est aussi baissé de coupe dans la rue il
ya des choses assez carrefour
enfourner aussi votre son qui peut avoir
une entrée en 2.0 en un son virtuel 5.1
canaux tout ça sur sonatrach est enfin
y'a rien de voter grâce et proche du
coeur c'est la détection automatique de
la typologie de contenus que vous êtes
en train de regarder la télé va savoir
automatiquement si vous en train de
regarder un film du sport ou un film
d'animation par exemple et ajuster les
réglages l'année
les détails sur l'image par exemple en
fonction aussi c'est du cinéma c'est du
sport
alors les joueurs pour la colorimétrie
ah et pour la télé film d'animation
également il ya plus besoin de passer
par votre télécommande est de passer par
je vais aller dans le mode quand vous
allez en mode cinéma la télé va
dorénavant le détecter automatiquement
et ajuster l'image en temps réel alors
la vie cachée lg en 2020 ayant un peu
plus de références en 2019 on avait
sorti deux référents suis qu'à une promo
l'aide d'une bonbonne à naucelle
en 2020 on aura dorénavant huit
références de la référence aux led
le 88 pouces qui existait déjà en 2010
d'heure et une nouvelle taille 77 pouces
ça veut dire qu'on est encore plus
performant vous n'arrivez à faire
rentrer 33 millions de pixels dans une
taille de 77 12 dorénavant en termes de
densité de pixels c'est du vrai blade of
technology
ça c'est pour le led et pour le lcd led
à naucelle
il y aura trois références différentes
avec deux tailles d'écran chacune à
chaque fois en 65 et en 75 points
nano 95 la no 97 et nano 99,98 référence
wicca chez lg maglica s'est pas encore
un truc qui parlent trop ça marche et ça
commence il démarrage de l'histoire mais
le vrai événement pour l'avicca cette
année c'est les jeux olympiques de tokyo
qui vont être capté et diffusé au japon
en 8k
donc c'est le premier événement majeur
qui va bénéficier du traitement
médiatique en u cas on démarre
l'histoire donc il faut suivre d'un
point de vue produits et avoir l'offre
ici derrière vers démocratiser la ducati
france
ça va ça va rendre concret le démarrage
de la vie car en tout cas été marc et la
pédagogie et la démocratisation qui va
prendre quelques années quand même ou
que les contenus soient commence à être
filmée xcalibur 8 ha ça apprendra que
deux temps une des grosses tendances
existantes et depuis quelques années
c'est que les écrans sont toujours plus
grand
taille standard c'est plus 40 pouces on
arrive de plus en plus vers 55 pouces
maintenant les écrans 55 65 75 77 88
sauf qu'un écran toujours plus grand
regardez pas chez vous un écran noir que
vous devez subir
trouver des moyens pour que votre écran
à que votre téléviseur on s'intègre
manière de plus en plus harmonieuse
le joli
avec votre design et comment vous
envisagez votre intérieur chez
on a commencé ça il ya quelques années
et j'ai avec le premier relais format
wallpapers qu'on apprenne
vous allez
roulette
et du coup il met en avant la finesse
exceptionnelle que permet la technologie
oled
je vous rappelle que l'eau l'aisne il
n'y a pas de dalle une rétro éclairage
parce que les pixels sur toutes les
missives qui permet d'avoir une taille
et une finesse d'écran qui est
aujourd'hui inégalable sur le marché cet
écran wallpapers ne fait que 4 mm
d'épaisseur de autant bas toute la
connectique de l'écran est déportée dans
la barre de son
ici
si comme ça vous avez un écran posé sur
votre mur qui fait uniquement 4 mm
d'épaisseur
c'est la première prouesse vous avez
réussi à faire il ya quelques années
face à l'émoi
deuxième point est toujours lié au
design est toujours lié à l'oled hockey
un écran de 4 mm c'est très fin
dorénavant on arrive à le rendre
flexible peut rendre flexible jusqu'à
laurent
fulham
on revient en téléviseur ou mac vous a
présenté au ces os l'an dernier qui
était le produit star du cs 2019
l'apu est innovations technologiques de
ces dix dernières années on va dire sur
la télé il est là votre télé quand vous
la regardez pas satisfait un écran à
vous n'avez pas à subir
la télé ou
c'est pareil
[Musique]
et l'on ressort on
arrimé comme c'est le cas ici
coûte une nouvelle manière d'envisager
la vie les chevaux vu que la télé
disparaît
beaucoup de verdure
plus obligés de la m contre un mur ou
émettre des étagères pour émettre une
bibliothèque derrière vous pouvez mettre
tel aménagement
la télé en 2020 dans la gamme all est
toujours dans ce souci d'intégrer au
mieux des téléviseurs dans votre
intérieur
on sort une nouvelle gamme la série g
galerie en l'occurrence qui comme si
vous avez un tableau
sur votre mur chez nous la télévision
autant bas c'est une télévision oled iv
2 cm d'épaisseur
pour la taille 65
par exemple
il n'y a pas de problème de différence
un conteneur de la terrible qu'est
l'école
complètement je vous défie de la télé
les ordres par le bas en une seule fois
toute la connectique est embarqué
derrière la télé les enceintes sont
aussi dans la télé il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir une enceinte supplémentaires
comme c'est le cas pour les wallpapers
ont été déportés dans l'enceinte
plus de la télé nouveauté cette année
sur la gamme aux lettres la gamme
galerie pour avoir une télé de tableau
comme moi que l'on rit sur les costumes
globale en fait on en trouve partout
dans la maison
ce soit le ragga la télé qui
effectivement très connue at the disco
et onctueuse et franck des préférences
il ya effectivement puisqu'ils électro
engagés on voit que les solutions qu'on
comptait global
tu rentres chez toi et alger qui la
déclarera effectivement la partie
restauration perry connectivité l'idée
c'est quoi c'est d'être aux prises à
360° ont tous les moments de convient je
vous rappelle de ce qu en algérie ce que
manager c'est life is good la vie est
belle et derrière ça le but c'est
vraiment de faciliter la vie des
consommateurs de faciliter la vie des
gens à tous les endroits la thématique
et de la signature du c est cette année
sur le stand lg c'est any where is the
vault
vous faciliter la vie vaut faire en
sorte que de la télé au réfrigérateur à
l'aspirateur robot est la porte d'entrée
avec les systèmes de livraison
faire votre propre potager à l'intérieur
de chez vous comment on peut faire pour
vous aider dans votre tâche du quotidien
et faire enfants tous et dégager du
temps pour faire d'autres activités
faire vous loisirs les rendre votre vie
plus belle
j'aurais plaisir
[Musique]
e
mais
[Musique]
le